but this is the thing about the whole
Flat Earth round earth thing like why
people care if people believe in the
Earth the way the Bible describes it why
do people get so mad about that does the
bible describe as flat yeah it does with
the Dome the firmament everything why do
people get mad at people if they just
describe the Earth the way the oldest
history book describes yeah so this mean
you think it's flat yep you do yeah I do
Google uh images of satellites I've
never seen a satellite that was real I'm
just saying I'm not a flat arur I'm just
saying yeah that is very strange now
that you bring that up this is what
changed me when um I looked into um
emergency Landings why would they why
are they selling us on round that's not
the only thing they selling you on they
selling you on Space you don't think
they're real you don't think Sun's real
no no no sun is real the Sun and the
Moon is real okay but out of space it's
not